let's consider a system in which there
is no non conservative work and there is
a potential energy associated with
forces in the system and for an example
let's write our potential energy like a
following will model some system by the
following function B X cubed and we know
that our definition of force is that
it's minus the change in potential
energy so if we differentiate this our
force is a function of X and because of
that minus sign you always have to be
careful when you take that type of
derivative we get as far as the force
goes to ax minus 3b x squared now we ask
ourselves where does this force vanish
so if we look at the zero points for the
force we can see immediately that
there's one x equals zero the other one
if we set to ax equal to three be x
squared tells us that we have another
zero point at two-thirds over two-thirds
a over B now let's also for our example
just put some numbers in for some
simplicity let's write this as four
joules per meter squared for a why do we
have meters squared well the units of
potential energy are joules and we're
multiplying by x squared and so you can
see that B also we're gonna write it as
2 joules meter to the minus 3 and if we
put those numbers in we can see that
we'll get 8 over 6 and 8 over 6 is just
4/3 and that will be in meters where the
other zero point is so that's nice but
we'd like to do some properties of these
zero points if we had a particle that we
started with some energy
one zero point where would it go what
would it do at the other point so in
order to understand a little bit more
detail about these zero points let's
make a plot of our potential energy U of
X verse X now to begin with we want to
ask ourselves how does this function
behave and for big values of X the X
cubed piece will dominate and if we're
positive X we dominate with a negative
value for potential energy so our
potential energy function goes off into
negative infinity as X goes to infinity
now on the other side of the scale the X
cubed term will dominate for negative
values of X but this term is negative
and that's negative so up here
it will go off to infinity in the
positive direction now where are the
zeros of the potential function there's
one obviously one at x equals zero and
with these values it's not a hundred
percent obvious immediately but 4x
squared minus 2 B X cubed if you set X
equal to 2 4 times 2 is 8 B 2 times 2 4
times 4 is 16 if B is 2 and X is 2
that's 16 so we get a cancellation at x
equals 2 and so we have a point up here
I'm sorry that's our zero point at x
equals 2 now we said that the force at x
equals 4/3 had a zero and so if we plot
this function it's gonna look something
like that
now let's focus on these two points
right here where our force is zero
remember that this is minus the slope
and so we can see immediately that these
two points have zero slope and so the
force is zero there notice potential
energy always depends on a reference
point so whether the potential energy is
zero not is not crucial but the physical
fact that the force is zero there has
physical meaning so here this is one of
our points X X F F X 0 now what is the
property of this point well suppose we
ask ourselves if the particle were just
displaced slightly from this position
where the force is 0 which way with the
force point well in order to answer a
question like that we can look at the
slopes on either side of the zero so
over here the slope is negative but the
force is minus the slope so f of X is
positive on this side and so if a
particle is displaced a little bit from
the zero point it moves off to the right
and it will continue to feel a force in
this direction and so it will move away
from this zero point of the force now on
the other side we do the same type of
argument and over here the slope is
positive but the force is negative so
again what we see on this side the
particle will move away from this zero
point and so if our particle just
started there and it had a little bit of
kinetic energy it would move one way or
the other away from that point and so we
call this an unstable equilibrium point
and that's an abbreviation for
equilibrium now what about this zero
point over here well we already know
that is the particle if a particle is on
this side of the zero it feels a force
this way but what if our particle
we're on this side well once again we
analyze the slope the slope is negative
forces minus the slope so it's positive
so everywhere on this side the particle
is getting a restoring force back to
equilibrium and so if we displace this
particle just on either side if it
doesn't have enough energy to get over
this point then the particle will stay
around this area and that what is why we
give this point the name of stable
equilibrium point